foreign
[Music]
and welcome to the Nano select
presentation about the benefits of cell
sorting prior to genomic application
workflows
we are pleased to participate in the
genetics virtual week and today we have
two speakers for you first we'll hear
from Emily bozek product manager here at
nanoselect Emily will discuss why low
pressure cell sorting can reduce noise
in sequencing data and how it ensures an
end-to-end successful three-prime
rna-seq workflow
next we'll hear from Dr Nicole jagnamdin
application scientist at nanoselect
Nicole will highlight how microfluidic
cell sorting compares to traditional
cell sorting for sample preparation
prior to 10x genomics applications
if you have any questions feel free to
submit them through the labyrinths
platform and we'll be sure to get back
to you
good morning everyone my name is Emily
bozik and I am the product manager for
the wolf at Nano select biomedical
today I'll be covering High viability
cell sorting for single cell 3-prime
rna-seq
so the agenda for today
um I would like to cover uh some issues
that users may run into when they're
completing a three-prime RNA seek
protocol
um I'd like to review why low pressure
cell sorting can reduce noise and
sequencing data
I'd also like to cover
um how to complete a full end-to-end
workflow for a successful three-prime
rna-seq experiment uh with uh cell
sorting as a sample prep stage
and then at the very end I'd like to go
over a case study from a customer site
at UCSD which is in partnership with the
Shiley eye institutes around a neuronal
gene expression study
so first of all uh why would researchers
want to use three prime rna-seq as
opposed to other rnac methods so for
some people it's important to understand
that for traditional RNA seat it
generates sequencing libraries from
Whole transcripts uh like this top
example shown here
uh as opposed to three prime RNA seek
which only generates a single initial
Library molecule purse transcripts which
is complementary to three prime end
sequences as shown in this bottom
example
one limitation of the more widely used
longer transcript rna-seq method is that
those longer transcripts are represented
by more reads than the shorter
transcripts which was uh may result in a
biased estimation of expression levels
so three prime rna-seq would suggest
that it has a greater power to detect
expression variation using that
particular method
other advantages to three prime RNA C uh
are that it typically costs half or less
than that compared to some of those
other single cell methods
in general it has a simpler Library prep
protocol so kind of less Hands-On
activities to do
and because it uses fewer reads than
traditional rna-seq it tends to be more
suitable
for labs that may have you know smaller
NGS instruments or potentially larger
sample sets so kind of amending that
protocol for for those particular use
cases and then again just to kind of
reiterate three prime rna-seq is
typically most useful to figure out
differential gene expression from
different sample sets
so typically when users are going
through rna-seq and then also for three
prime RNA seek they like to use uh facts
technology so fluorescent activated cell
sorting technology to dispense us a
particular population of cells um using
this low cytometry method
um to dispense into single Wells of a
PCR plate now the issue is that
traditional facts for a number of
different reasons isn't typically well
suited for a number of genomics assays
including three prime rna-seq so some of
those issues number one are just around
time and being able to schedule using uh
some of these complex uh instruments as
a part of the core facility at a
university or some other Institute I can
just be really kind of cumbersome to
have to travel to that core facility
depending on how large campuses
scheduled at time so that it works with
um you know your particular sample type
which may be coming from in Vivo samples
and really just not having that
convenience of being able to kind of
work around your schedule and having to
work with someone else's
uh there's also
um a higher risk potentially of
contaminating your samples uh from uh
previous samples carryover because these
traditional instruments don't have a
disposable fluidics or those lines
um from the fluidics part traveling into
the machine
um typically are not replaced that often
and can be subject to microbial
contamination over the course of a
period of time now they do have cleaning
methods but that doesn't always
guarantee that it's uh that you're
completely getting rid of free nucleic
acids or free RNA that could be floating
around and then potentially
contaminating uh your sample and then
therefore
um you know contamining your sequencing
data set
it can also just be simply quite
expensive to optimize if you're starting
a new uh assay a new sequencing type of
essay and have to figure out some of the
correct settings or cell populations
that you want to
um you know probe deeper into just the
cost around scheduling that time and
um availability
um just can be can be quite expensive
and then finally
um probably
maybe perhaps the most important for
some genomics experiments is that these
traditional sorters the jet near and
cuvette based ones
um can induce a lot of cell stress uh by
high pressure uh decompression shock and
then a electrostatic charge on those
cells that are getting dispensed into uh
into plates so all these things by
inducing cell stress from all those
perspects can have an effect on gene
expression and potentially Cloud
um the
types of conclusions that you would come
to from that type of data so you know
just inducing more error than than
needed potentially
now when you're uh doing cell sorting uh
for genomics experiments it's very
important uh to get rid of dead cells
debris and doublets and even with three
prime rna-seq you definitely want to
have a very good sample prep uh Upstream
of this it's quite typical uh for a lot
of different sample types to have a high
degree of dead cells and debris so for
this particular sample you're seeing
here in red on a 2d scatter plot a
support scatter versus sides better a
high degree of dead cells and debris
shown here in red this particular sample
was stained with pi and then you can
view that with fluorescence with this
uh with the right side of this histogram
plot over here so there's a very high
degree of a pi positive or dead cells uh
contaminating this sample which would
really have users potentially having a
fair amount of free RNA or free nucleic
acids in their sample which could you
know kind of cloud and you know make the
the data set a lot more noisy than it
needs to be
um other users will also find uh
potentially that their uh samples are
quite sticky and uh can have a high
degree of tablets so doublets can induce
false positives and kind of cloud
sequencing data a little bit more
um some doublets typically and fluster
chemistry plots uh show up
um over here
and um you can just make the data a
little bit noisier also than it needs to
be
so all of this um with uh traditional
sorters knowing that
um you uh because of that high pressure
and shock decompression you can really
get
um a lot of partially degraded total RNA
or um you know many peaks of completely
uh degraded
um total RNA which really will have an
effect on the quality of your sequencing
data set
the solution uh to all of these issues
that I mentioned if you're trying to go
through three prime rna-seq and then
also use a type of post cytometry-based
cell sorting system would be to use
microfluidics so the wolf bench top
Sorter and N1 single cell dispenser from
nanosoy allows users to do a very uh
simple spell sorting uh single cell
dispensing into PCR plates at very low
pressure so less than 2 PSI no
decompression shock and of course no
electrostatic charge
so uh the wolf in combination with the
N1 single cell dispenser so the wolf
with the N1 single cell dispenser uh
will gently uh sort a cell type of your
choosing into PCR plates uh directly
Upstream of those three prime rna-seq
kits
so uh to validate that the wolf and N1
system does actually give you you know
good single cell efficiency
uh we did a number of experiments uh
comparing single cell efficiency uh from
flat bottom culture plates versus the
more conical bottom uh PCR plates what
we did here uh it was an experiment with
beads where uh for the culture plates
um we did a full eight plates of 96 well
dispensing uh versus 13 plates of uh 96
well PCR plates uh we did not find any
significant difference between those
single cell sorting efficiencies between
those two different plate types uh these
cell filter plates on average had
um
uh 98 single cell efficiency while on
average the PCR plates showed uh 90
single cell efficiency
so in order to fully validate that the
wolf and N1 system uh does work well for
three prime rna-seq we did a few
experiments
um by using the kaijin upx 3 Prime
transcription kit so two plates of 293 t
t cells were dispensed using the N1 and
then Library prep was completed using
that kyoc 3 Prime transcriptome kit cdna
was sequenced and analyzed and the
estimated cell number per well was
defined as the following criteria so if
it was less than 100 genes that was
relegated to being zero cells if it was
a hundred to
1499 genes that was determined to be one
cell per Weld and anything above 1500
genes was two or more cells per well so
we estimated for one plate
um based on this analysis that about 72
percent of one of the 96 volt plates had
one cell per well
and then 92 percent of the second plate
had one cell per well
so these results just show that the wolf
in conjunction with the N1 are able to
successfully plate a single cell into a
PCR plate and then actually give you
relevant results for three prime uh RNA
sequencing
with that uh we do present
um a full end-to-end workflow uh using
the wolf cell sorter arms the kyoc UPS
320 Prime transform kit uh four three
prime rnac so all users have to do is
begin with a mixture of suspended cells
load it onto the wolf cell sorter
um you will figure out which population
of cells are actually trying to sort and
then you'll dispense it using the N1
single cell dispenser dispense those
single cells into 96 well chiasique
plates which are pre-loaded with the
cell lysis buffer so those cells then
lice and single cell RNA can then be
reverse transcribed and each RNA
molecule is then given a unique
molecular index or Umi
uh with that they're also assigned a
well-specific cell IDs up to 384 Wells
and then following reverse transcription
with integrated template switching all
those cdnas can be combined into one
tube enabling
um kind of a full Library Construction
for the wolf and uh this three prime
kits uh really allows you to go through
a high throughput Next Generation uh
sequencing
workflow using polyadenylated rnas and
then uh sequencing using uh alumina
sequencers
the way that kiosync UPS time
transcription kit works is that every
one of these wells in the plate has that
unique uh primer
Umi and cell ID mix into each well so
you really can pool all those Wells that
had a single cell in it into one tube
for Library construction and then
finally with the cell analysis that you
would do
um after sequencing all of that
depending on the reads that you have uh
you would just need to understand the
original ratio
compared to the experimental ratio to be
able to determine how many umis uh there
were per that Gene per the sample set so
that allows users to truly kind of
understand at the end of their
experiment
um how they can compare Umi reads to the
beginning mRNA or the number of genes
that they originally had in that sample
so finally the case study that I'd like
to highlight with one of our customers
at UCSD working with the Shiley Eye
Institute I was around a specific set of
experiments
um related to glaucoma and then
eventually other eye related diseases
like macular degeneration so this
particular lab had two different
populations of mice so wild type mice
and then mutant mice mutant mice groups
have a particular variance that is
believed to be protective against
glaucoma so by using control neurons for
each of those groups and then treating
those
um eyes with iops so intraocular
pressure you can
uh isolate those particular neurons from
those retinas and then sort them on the
wolf
um via CD 90.2 by dating so these uh
four different conditions the wild type
Mouse control versus IOP and then mutant
Mount mutant Mouse control versus IOP
these four different sets of neurons
then were
sorted on the wolf uh via CD 90.2 Fitzy
uh dating so this was a just a typical
of immunostating uh protocol where
um
he essentially just sorted based on
positive CD 90.2 Fitzy signal and then
plated into those Kaya seek plates so
single cell plating into kind of safe
plates and then completing the library
construction NGS sequencing and then
finally data analysis so coming out of
that
um the group was able to find VIA this
uh tisney analysis at each of those four
different groups of neurons actually did
have
um different types of gene expression
and you can see those clusters based on
those four different conditions over
here
and then finally
um looking at the top 145 genes by a
hierarchical clustering of those gene
expression levels you can actually see
you know really different expression
based on the condition
of the uh types of neurons that
different genes really are expressed in
different levels
um based on you know where they came
from so
you know knowing all of that the
molecular mechanisms of glaucoma and
then some of these other uh eye related
diseases that this group is working on
um will be able to be you know begin to
be elucidated uh using this particular
method
so
um just in summary uh we were able to
show that a high quality sample prep
using uh the wolf and N1 uh cell sorting
system was pretty key to generating good
quality sequencing data uh the three
prime kind of seek upx kids from kaijin
are compatible with the wolf
self-sorting system
and then that piece kit and the Wolf are
accessible tools for a real life case
study for researchers to uh study single
cell gene expression in neuronal cell
populations
hello thanks for joining me today my
name is Nicole jagnanden and I'm an
application scientist at Nano select
biomedical I will be discussing how you
can benefit from using a cell sorter
prior to your 10x genomics experiments
during this presentation I will be
talking about the issues users may run
into when not taking the necessary
sample preparation steps for a 10x
genomics experiment
how low pressure cell sorting can reduce
background noise and improve your
sequencing results
how cell sorting fits into a 10x
genomics workflow and then finally I
will be going over the results from two
10x experiments we did comparing
unsorted versus sorted pbmcs and another
10x experiment with stem cells using the
wolf cell Sorter and the BD facts aria2
for sample prep
when preparing your sample for a single
cell sequencing it is important that you
treat your cells as gently as possible
things such as using wide bore pipette
tips avoiding excessive vortexing using
gentle centrifuge speeds and using the
optimal buffer for your cell type are
all important techniques you should use
you should also remove any debris dead
cells and cellular Aggregates from your
sample
not taking these precautions can lead to
a clog during your gem generation step
degraded RNA poor Library generation
inaccurate sequencing results and a
significant loss in money
fluorescent activated cell sorters can
be a valuable tool in your sample prep
workflow for 10x genomics applications
debris dead cells and sticky cells or
doublets can all be removed with a cell
sorter in addition if you're only
interested in a specific cell type from
a mixed population you can tag these
cells with fluorescent antibodies to
isolate your targeted cell type
however high pressure cell disorders can
cause shear stress on cells that can
lead to cell damage and gene expression
changes that can alter your sequencing
results
in addition because the fluidic system
and these traditional cells orders are
fixed into their machines and not
disposable you run the risk of
cross-contamination between your samples
which could also lead to inaccurate
results
conventional cell sorters that use the
cuvette or Jet and air sorting mechanism
can exert anywhere from 20 to 70 pounds
per square inch of pressure on your
cells which also causes this
decompression shock once they exit out
of the nozzle this can cause a lot of
shear stress on your cells
the wolf however emits just under two
pounds per square inch of pressure on
your cells and therefore there's no
decompression shock once they exit out
of the Sorting cartridge
and so cells end up being much healthier
and functional for your Downstream
assays
as I mentioned before cell sorters can
be used to remove dead cells debris and
doublets from your samples
here's an example using Cho cells where
the starting population of dead cells
shown here in red was 60 percent after
sorting only six percent of the
population was shown to be dead cells
using a height burst width or area plot
on a cell sorter can also allow you to
identify and remove doublets from your
sample
now if you're only interested in a
specific cell type you can also isolate
that too by using fluorescently tagged
antibodies while removing dead cells and
doubles at the same time
here's an example where we wanted to
isolate the live T cells from a pbmc
population
our starting population had 55 live
cells which we were able to identify
using a viability dye and 21 of the
cells were identified as T cells using
the CD3 Alexa floor 40 marker
after sorting for the live CD3 positive
T cells we were able to increase this
live population to 92 percent
and purify the CD3 positive population
to 98
and so the main takeaway from this slide
is that your sorted population is going
to be a much healthier population of
cells for your single cell genomic
Library prep which means you're going to
have higher RNA quality and therefore
better sequencing results
another advantage to using the wolf cell
sorter versus conventional cell sorters
is that the wolf uses disposable sterile
cartridges
this means that you don't have to worry
about there being any
cross-contamination between your samples
everything that your sample and sheath
touch go through this disposable
cartridge so that you can simply switch
out your cartridge between samples
this feature along with the capability
of the wolf to be used in a biosafety
cabinet allow you to truly work in
sterile conditions when preparing your
sample for single cell library
generation
the wolf self-sorter can be used prior
to loading your sample into the chromium
controller
during this step you would isolate your
target cells and remove any dead cells
or aggregates
after sorting your cells if necessary
you would concentrate your sample down
to the 10x chromium kit recommendations
prior to loading your sample into the
chromium controller
from there you would proceed with their
Library generation protocol and then you
would sequence your samples
in order to validate the genomic
benefits of using a gentle cell sorter
prior to loading your sample into the
chromium controller
pbmcs were isolated from human blood and
then split into two samples in one
sample 10 000 cells were spun down and
then directly loaded into the chromium
system to serve as our unsorted sample
we then took the remaining pbmcs and
stained them with a viability die and
then ran these samples through the wolf
cell sorter
we then sorted for the viable pbmc
population by gating out debris
and dead cells using a viability die and
doublets
we then took 10 000 of these woof sorted
cells and then loaded these into the
chromium this was our sorted sample
both of these samples were then
sequenced through the alumina high seek
4000 and then ran through the cell
Ranger Pipeline with the help of the
UCSD genomics core
the cell range Ranger summary produces
several key metrics about the RNA and
sequencing quality the sequencing
analysis for our two samples showed that
there was almost three times more median
genes per cell and our assorted sample
compared to our unsorted sample there
was also more total genes detected in
our assorted sample
both of these results show a higher
Library complexity in our woof sorted
sample there was also a lower percentage
of reads that were not associated with a
cell in our sorted sample
during the Single Cell partitioning step
each cell is tagged with a specific
barcode so reads that don't have a
barcode are not associated with a cell
and so this result means that there was
less ambient RNA likely from dead cells
in our assorted samples
we then looked at the Disney plots
generated from these two samples
these testing plots here are showing the
heat map of the number of unique
molecular identifiers or RNA transcripts
in each cell
blue meaning a lower amount of Umi
counts was detected per cell and read
meaning a meaning a higher amount of Umi
accounts you can see that there are much
more blue dots in the unsorted pvmcs
meaning that there was much less RNA
transcripts per cell compared to the
sorted pdmcs in fact there was almost
four times more median Umi accounts per
cell
this dramatic increase in Umi counts is
likely due to the fact that there was
less dead cells in the sorted sample
dead cells tend to have less RNA and
more fragmented RNA
there was also two more clusters of
cells detected in the assorted sample
and the Clusters and transcriptional
profiles between each cell type were
more distinct because of the higher
Library complexity and reduced
background noise from sorting
we then wanted to see how these were
results compare to other cell sorters so
we took some induced pluripotent stem
cells and split them into three samples
one sample served as our unsorted
control and the other two samples were
stained with a viability die and either
sorted through the BD facts aria2 or the
wolf
both sorted samples were sorted at the
same time to exclude dead cells and
doublets the Aria sorted sample was
sorted by the flow core at Sanford
Burnham crevice using the 100 Micron
nozzle and at 20 psi compared to the 50
Micron channel in the wolf cartridge at
2 PSI
50 000 live stem cells were sorted on
both machines and then around 10 000
cells were loaded into the chromium
controller for Library prep and
sequencing
all three of these samples had cdna
libraries generated using the chromium
next-gem single cell 3 Prime Library kit
and sequencing was done with the
Illumina Nova sync
data analysis for these samples was also
run through the cell Ranger pipeline
the sample quality metrics for these
samples showed that there was a
three-fold increase in the wolf sample
and a two-fold increase in the facts
Aria 2 sample and the number of median
genes per cell which again shows that
sorting results in an increase in
library complexity
we also saw an increase in the number of
median Umi counts per cell with the
highest increase in the wolf sample
sorting also resulted in an increase in
the percentage of reads that map to the
transcriptome
having a lower percentage of reads that
map to the transcriptome indicates
fragmented RNA or contamination so this
result shows that there was an
improvement in the RNA quality and less
contamination in the sorted samples
overall this simple experiment shows
that sorting enables you to get more
data per cell and this may be even more
improved by sorting your samples with a
gentle cell sorter such as the wolf
in conclusion the quality of your
sequencing results is directly dependent
on how you prepare your sample the wolf
cell sorter is a 10x genomics compatible
product for sample preparation enabling
more data per dollar spent on genomics
reagents
and using the worst cell sorter for your
10x genomics applications it can result
in improved Library complexity and less
background noise from dead cells and
debris while eliminating the risk for
cross-contamination
and that concludes my talk for today if
you want to learn more about these two
experiments that I talked about please
visit the scientific section on our
website